figa alive bonjour on est en direct
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de la
guerre en Ukraine et des armes utilisées
lors de ce conflit pour pas être sujet
je suis avec Amaury coutancé bonjour
Amaury bonjour Vincent journaliste au
Figaro avec vous on va décrypter un peu
tous ces armes et comment elles sont
utilisées lors de ce conflit puisque
c'est un sujet que vous traitez pour Le
Figaro que vous êtes traité à nombreuses
reprises en plus et ça ait plus le
conflit avance plus il y a de nouvelles
armes puis de nouvelles armes donc
effectivement alors n'hésitez pas sur
dans les commentaires à nous poser vos
questions on y répond au mieux comme
d'habitude et vous n'hésitez pas non
plus voilà à vous poser à la fois sur le
site du Figaro et aussi sur Youtube que
nous diffusons aussi via ce canal Amaury
on va passer à la première image que je
voudrais vous montrer c'est c'est le
Javelin c'est ça c'est un missile
Javelin alors on sait pas Javelin ou
Jablines javel là où j'avais une c'est
comme on veut une c'est la version
anglaise donc c'est c'est très américain
et c'est ces armes les missiles Javelin
où javeline sont des armes en T-shirt
elles ont été beaucoup livrées au début
du surtout les experts disent que ça
correspond aussi à une phase du conflit
parce qu'à ce moment-là les Russes
avancaient un peu de part et d'autre de
l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens avaient des
élections
sur les arrières russes parce qu'ils
avancaient en longue colonne et
notamment grâce à ses missiles ils ont
pu arrêter un certain nombre de colonnes
et en tout cas empêcher leur
ravitaillement dans certains nombre de
véhicules c'est c'est ce qui a permis
aux Ukrainiens de d'aussi bien résister
sur les premières semaines de conflit
c'est ça absolument en fait ces armes il
y en a déjà qui avaient été livré au
préalable déjà depuis 2018 à l'Ukraine
on sait en tout cas il y en a eu plus de
5000 qui ont été livrés entre février et
avril j'ai pas des chiffres plus récents
malheureusement on sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup qui ont été utilisés
ce qui est intéressant aussi avec ces
armes c'est ce que l'on appelle des
armes manpad c'est à dire qu'elles
peuvent être utilisées par un soldat
comme sur l'image et que ce soldat
naturellement peut se mouvoir et enfin
frapper les arrières de l'ennemi on va
au cours aujourd'hui des vidéos où on
voit des chars ou des blindés en tout
cas russe qui sont attaqués grâce à des
javelines c'est à dire que alors on
imagine que c'est quand même assez lourd
c'est un dispositif qu'on pourrait
qualifier d'assez léger c'est un
dispositif en tout cas plus léger que
d'autres armes on va pouvoir parler ce
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
que c'est très très précis et que un
certain nombre en fait de blindés russes
ont des faiblesses notamment dans le sur
la partie haute et c'est pour ça qu'il y
a des images un peu bizarres on voyait
des blindés avec des grillages parce
qu'il se protégeait de ses de ses
missiles en espérant que le missile
viendrait se loger au creux du grillage
et qu'il resterait son exploser sur le
blindé très bien alors on va passer au
deuxième à la deuxième arme utilisée
c'est le Milan le Milan alors c'est
français alors le nuancier français
c'est l'une des armes qui fait partie de
notre trame en T-shirt de nos unités
d'infanterie c'est un très bon engin ça
a été utilisé voilà ça a été conçu dans
les années 60 ça a été surtout utilisé
dans les années 70 au sein de l'armée
française ça peut tirer ben alors voilà
on peut le voir c'est une portée de 1900
mètres donc quasiment 2 km avec une
cadence de 2 à 3 coups par minute ce qui
est quand même assez bien et c'est la
même chose que le Javelin c'est à dire
que c'est une norme EN t-shirt ou anti
blindé et il y en a un certain nombre
qui ont été livrés alors le nombre exact
n'a pas été révélé mais on sait que la
France qui était très prudente sur la
livraison d'armes la révélé par la voix
du près du président de la République
Emmanuel Macron au mois de juin dernier
dans une interview à Ouest-France où il
annonçait également la livraison des
fameux canon César c'est un peu le
pendant français du Javelin donc
exactement ça effectivement donc alors
on peut le voir là c'est 12 kg donc
c'est en fait c'est le poids d'une
trottinette électrique à Paris si jamais
les gens veulent avoir un peu un
référentiel donc c'est pas extrêmement
lourd alors évidemment qu'en cours des
kilomètres c'est c'est très très très
lourd mais le missile en tant que tel
est extrêmement précis il a une prix il
a une particularité c'est ce qu'on
appelle filoguidé c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un fil qui va le suivre depuis la base
de lancement jusqu'à l'explosion de
façon à ce que ce soit extrêmement
précis c'est une technologie qui est un
peu ancienne comment ça filou guide
alors on fait comment non non en fait il
y a un fil qui va suivre le missile
d'accord et depuis de la base de
lancement jusqu'à jusqu'à ou qu'il veut
toucher d'accord donc pour savoir d'où
vient le missile et ça permet de
précision assez importante très bien
donc ça c'est pour le Milan on va passer
au à l'arme suivante qui est
celle-ci alors c'est un c'est un Stinger
ça c'est un mix alors et là ça sert plus
à tirer au sol ça sert à tirer en l'air
c'est ça exactement c'est un missile
entier aérien encore une fois comme le
Milan et comme le Javelin c'est un
manpad c'est-à-dire qu'un homme peut le
porter en se promenant le singer il est
également une particularité c'est que
c'est l'une des armes qui avait été
livrées par les américains aux Afghans
pendant les années enfin pendant la
guerre d'avion entre 79 et la fin des
années 80 il avait été extrêmement utile
notamment aux avegans pour enfin
supprimer la suprématie aérienne russe
qui reposait beaucoup sur les
hélicoptères on a vu beaucoup d'images
surtout début du conflit de
d'hélicoptère et très très peu d'avions
qui étaient visés par des Stingers c'est
une arme qu'aujourd'hui est encore
utilisée mais un peu moins utilisé
puisque la suprématie aérienne russe n'a
pas été acquise et que les hélic sont de
moins en moins de sorties sur les têtes
d'opération oui c'est un peu alors je
sais pas si on peut dire ça mais est-ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est des armes
plutôt du début du conflit voilà
exactement en fait il y a eu plusieurs
phases on pourrait dire dans le conflit
je pense que l'un des moments clés ça a
été la découverte de bout de chat lors
de la retraite russe aux alentours de
Kiev donc vers la fin avril dernier à ce
moment-là les occidentaux vont commencer
à livrer de l'armement lourd beaucoup
plus de blindés etc donc sur lesquels on
aura l'occasion de revenir au début ça
c'est c'était de l'armement un peu plus
léger on livre également des casques des
gilets pare-balles etc mais ces
armements ont quand même permis au début
du conflit aux Ukrainiens de pouvoir
résister face à l'avancée russe et
globalement personne ne croyait que les
Ukrainiens pouvaient résister mais ça
aura quand même permis de résister et
donc dans un second temps ça a permis
d'une certaine manière la livraison
d'armement un peu plus lourd aux forces
américaines effectivement donc en fait
au début on on a oui enfin c'était
plutôt des armes légères au début puis
ensuite on est passé sur de plus en plus
gros on va dire plus gros plus gros
massif c'est ça exactement en fait c'est
aussi correspondait à une période c'est
à dire qu'on pourrait diviser le conflit
en Ukraine aussi par les buts russes il
semble qu'au début les Russes qui ont
foncé vers Kiev avaient pour objectif de
prendre la capitale et probablement d'y
installer un pouvoir à leur solde dans
un second temps la Russie avait annoncé
une deuxième phase de l'opération se
concentrant sur le donbasse sur ces
territoires donc séparatiste à l'est au
sud de l'Ukraine et à ce moment-là les
Occidentaux ont commencé à livrer alors
qui décanon César et d'autres des canons
d'artillerie un peu plus importants
effectivement alors on va parler aussi
d'autres armes qu'on a beaucoup entendu
parler alors ça c'est on part sur les
drones donc là c'est un drone donc ça
n'a pas de pilote non et c'est quelque
chose qui a été
primordial je ne sais pas mais ce qui a
eu une grande importance aussi dans les
premiers mois du conflit tout à fait en
fait le drone beractar il avait été
notamment vu pendant la guerre des 44
jours entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan
puisque c'est la Turquie qui fabrique ça
ça coûte 5 millions de dollars à peu
près ce qui est extrêmement peu cher
pour un drone
il les Ukrainiens on avait un certain
nombre il y en a beaucoup qui présenter
ça peut voler environ 27 heures à 222
km/h donc c'est quand même assez rapide
et ça a été utilisé au début par les
Ukrainiens notamment pour aller frapper
la défense entière
russe et un certain nombre de véhicules
lourds à l'arrêt aux arrières de du
dispositif russe ça a permis énormément
de ralentir le dispositif russe et
notamment ça n'a pas permis à la Russie
d'avoir une suprématie aérienne c'est
également participé aussi le parce que
il faudra se rappeler lors d'une guerre
c'était pas franc contre front et on
essaie aussi de frapper les lignes
arrières et ce drone a servi à ça
justement exactement ça permet à ça et
pour revenir sur ce que ce que l'on
disait tout à l'heure sur la suprématie
aérienne généralement par exemple si on
prend l'invasion de l'Irak en 2003 par
les Américains les Américains ont tout
d'abord visé un certain nombre
d'installation d'abord la défense
anti-aérienne de façon à pouvoir
s'assumer avoir une suprématie aérienne
qui leur permet de viser des
infrastructures mais aussi justement ce
que vous disiez les arrières du
dispositif de l'ennemi et à partir de ce
moment là les forces seules peuvent
avancer beaucoup plus facilement
effectivement c'est drone alors c'est
des drones qui sont pas kamikazes des
zones qui lâchent un ou deux missiles
alors ça peut lâcher des missiles ça
peut un ou deux missiles ça peut
également être utilisé bien sûr en drone
kamikaze mais le drone kamikaze c'est le
drone que l'on évoquera peut-être plus
tard c'est le drone iranien le chef on
va le montrer maintenant du coup le chat
qui est ici alors on le voit aussi on le
voit de loin le le le le Shad euh je
crois que c'était une photo qui était
prise à Kiev après le bombardement du du
pont de kirsch ou en fait les Russes
sont acquis ces drones shot 136 qui sont
extrêmement intéressants alors eux pour
le coup ils ont une portée de 2000 km
donc c'est extrêmement important et eux
sont beaucoup plus utilisés comme des
drones kamikazes en ce moment ils sont
par exemple utilisés pour viser des
infrastructures électriques on sait que
depuis le bomba enfin en tout cas
l'accident pour le kirch présentant-le
comme ça le plan catch pour ceux qui
suivent pas au quotidien le conflit
c'est un pont qui relie la Crimée occupé
à la Russie et qui est centrale dans le
dispositif russe parce qu'il leur permet
ainsi d'acheminer des vives du matériel
etc le pont donc a été frappé il y a
quelques semaines et les Russes se sont
vengés on peut dire qu'il y a des
représailles et notamment ils ont visé
des centrales électriques de façon alors
voilà vous voulez vous montrer en même
temps voilà ce que vous voyez ici sur
cette carte on va on va agrandir pour
vous voir un peu mieux quand même mais
voilà le pont de Caire Apple on va
agrandir pour voir un peu mieux ici
voilà donc le pont de car je vous le
voyez ici il est en bas de la Crimée il
permettait d'avoir un court un passage
en fait elle a réussi en corridor c'est
tout à fait un corridor et les Russes
donc l'utiliser beaucoup pour les
Ukrainiens évidemment il était
inacceptable qu'un tel point soit
construit qu'il soit utilisé et on peut
on peut le voir d'ailleurs sur votre
carte les rues sont vengés en visant un
certain nombre de villes et
d'infrastructures électriques là on voit
créer free ni pro mais également il y a
eu car kif j'ai tenir et Kiev donc les
Russes ont visé ça aussi qu'aujourd'hui
c'est dramatique parce que 30% du
courant électrique
ukrainien et coupé et c'est évidemment
un enjeu important à l'approche de
l'hiver bien sûr il est peu probable que
c'est un impact direct sur le conflit
parce que bah les véhicules sont pas
électriques mais ça peut comme avant
l'impact au moins sur le soutien de
population au conflit et notamment sur
le froid tout simplement effectivement
donc voilà ça c'était pour ce qui
s'était passé au pont de kerche on va
essayer de retrouver cette image
alors il faut que je retrouve dans
toutes les voilà hop là donc avant de
avant d'aller sur les mig on va parler
tout à l'heure
ça c'est toujours les mêmes voilà donc
ça c'est les drones et donc c'est c'est
drôle là ils sont très dur à contrer en
fait il fonctionne un peu comme des
missiles guidés on pourrait dire ça
comme ça ils sont extrêmement dur à
contrer parce qu'ils sont pas
extrêmement gros donc on les repères
très difficilement radar également un
autre drone iranien qui s'appelle le mot
ager 6 alors je regarde bien pour bien
prononcer ils sont beaucoup plus petits
et eux ils ont une signature radar qui
est encore plus faible ils sont
également utilisés notamment ils avaient
utilisé était utilisé à carquive donc
dans l'est de l'Ukraine pour viser le
dispositif arrière ukrainien et la
Russie alors les experts divergent un
peu mais il est probable qu'en fait la
Russie qui a beaucoup beaucoup
sollicités sont stock de missiles et de
moins en moins de missiles et de
rencontres certaines difficultés pour
reconstituer ce stock et donc et acheter
ces drones à la à l'Iran qui est
d'ailleurs récemment reconnu avoir vendu
de tel drone et des armes à la Russie
les ustens des missiles guidées et comme
des comme des drones kamikazes qui sont
extrêmement efficaces on voit des vidéos
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a eu des bombardements sur la
flotte russe et sur certaines bases de
la Ford russe à Sébastopol et les Russes
ont découvert en fait des drones sous
main c'est des drones qui ont été
construits notamment un sur une base de
jet ski Canadiens sur lesquels ils ont
placé une bombe ils le lancent d'environ
environ 300 km et c'est extrêmement
dangereux c'est drone sous-marin
aujourd'hui on en sait on sait très peu
de choses dessus on sait que si
l'Ukraine obtient de tel drone
sous-marin qui sont extrêmement
performants face à la flotte russe de
Sébastopol la flotte russe de Sébastopol
ferait bien de se protéger parce que
c'est extrêmement dangereux surtout
c'est très difficilement détectable
c'est-à-dire on a pris un jet ski on a
enlevé le haut et on a mis une bombe à
la place exactement et et on pilote un
peu comme une voiture électrique en gros
son jet ski c'est ça exactement c'est à
dire que c'est piloté depuis la Terre le
jet ski a une infrastructure électrique
qui est reliée à un iPhone par exemple
ou un téléphone et ce Téléphone pilote
ce jet ski cette base de jet-ski jusqu'à
une cible et en l'occurrence cette
fois-ci ça a été un navire russe
et donc on comprend que si ça arrive à
être un peu industrialisé entre
guillemets si on a de plus en plus la
flotte russe comme vous le disiez peut
manger présent danger au niveau de la
Crimée puisque est-ce que la Russie a
toujours une suprématie maritime dans la
région c'est l'une des questions en tout
cas la flotte russe est extrêmement
présente et elle est extrêmement forte
l'une des questions qui va se poser
c'est de savoir si la Russie sera
capable de contrer des missiles quand il
Navy notamment
ukrainien ou en tout cas fourni par les
Occidentaux aux Ukrainiens qui
pourraient toucher sa flotte on sait
qu'une partie de la flotte de la mer
Noire a quitter ses vestes Paul pour
aller à novaury 6 et qui est au sud de
l'Ukraine au nord de Sotchi et qu'elle
s'est repliée là-bas on sait néanmoins
que la base de Sébastopol bien sûr est
très ancienne et très importante pour
pour les Russes la super aujourd'hui la
marine
ukrainienne n'est pas en mesure de
défaire la marine russe sur la mer Noire
néanmoins on sait qu'il le reste
quelques navires on ne sait pas
exactement combien on pense qu'ils sont
très mauvais état le la guerre maritime
que pourrait mener l'Ukraine dans ces
prochaines semaines c'est probablement
plutôt des missiles anti navire depuis
la Terre qui viserait les ports russes
notamment en très bien alors je vois que
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous rejoindre vous n'hésitez pas bien
sûr à nous poser vos questions on va
passer maintenant aux avions de combat
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle tout d'abord ça c'est un mig
c'est ça c'est un Mig 29 c'est un c'est
franchement un très très bel avion
c'était produit pour un guerre froide
dans les années 70 ça a l'air
particularité d'être le cinquième avion
le plus utilisé au monde et il y a alors
que c'est si vieux que ça alors que si
si vieux que ça mais en fait c'est
extrêmement performant et notamment un
certain nombre d'armées qui étaient de
pays qui est anciennement alliés avec
l'URSS l'utilise on sait que par exemple
la libyle on avait un certain nombre par
exemple je crois que l'Angola a
également un certain nombre mais
également des pays du de l'ex bloque de
l'Est comme par exemple le la Pologne
possède un certain nombre de ces de ces
avions
sont extrêmement intéressants pour
rechercher la supériorité aérienne donc
c'est plutôt des avions de combat
aériens ils peuvent tout de même là on
le voit d'ailleurs ils peuvent tout de
même porter des missiles et aller
frapper les arrières des de l'ennemi
mais est-ce qu'il est bien parce qu'il a
une faible signature radar mais il est
quand même plutôt fait pour la mission
de combat de courte durée et pour aller
chercher l'aviation ni puis revenir au
sol sera détailler et continuer le coin
alors quand on dit courte durée on parle
de combien de temps alors ça dépend de
l'intensité du feu bien sûr mais courte
durée alors c'est pas mesurable comme ça
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'en tout cas il ne
peut pas durer très longtemps parce que
ces performances sont assez anciennes
même si on sait qu'il y a des versions
qui ont été modernisées au fur et à
mesure du temps et on sait que dans tous
les cas le combat aérien est extrêmement
violent et que il y a des pertes qui
peuvent être importantes si jamais les
deux flottes enfin les deux flottes
aériennes sont équivalentes et alors on
l'a dit aussi mais pour livrer ces armes
là bien sûr là on peut pas passer par
les airs
ah non c'est enfin en tout cas c'est
très difficile ce que l'on ce que les en
tout cas ce qui a été une des rumeurs
c'est au début du on vers Mars Avril
dernier c'était que l'Occident et
notamment la Pologne elle est livrée de
tels avions à l'Ukraine et que les
Américains remplaceraient ses avions par
des avions américains ou plus plus
moderne
ça n'a pas abouti en tout cas ce qui
avait été évoqué c'est que ces avions là
auraient été envoyés en pièces détachées
à l'Ukraine ces avions là d'ailleurs
l'Ukraine comme la Russie en possède et
qu'ils auraient été ensuite utilisé sur
le sur le front d'accord donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas ce qui a été
retenu d'accord c'est-à-dire de les
monter soi-même de les monter soi-même
en tout cas pour déplacer de tels de
tels avions il faudrait des avions
extrêmement performance qui est le plus
utile en tout cas le moins dangereux au
niveau des bombardements c'est
probablement de les envoyer par le train
en pièces détachées très bien alors on
va passer sur le sur son pendant alors
je sais pas si on peut parler ça mais
est-ce que c'est son pendant non c'est
pas tout de suite l'iris on va parler
d'abord du Sukhoi
est-ce que c'est le pendant des Mig côté
russe alors les migly Russes également
en possède ça c'est plutôt un avion qui
a une autre fonction c'est ce qu'on
appelle un bombardier tactique c'est un
soukoy 34 je crois également d'ailleurs
que les Ukrainiens en ont il me semble
deux c'est un avion qui a été mis en
service en 2011 c'est un avion qui est
assez polyvalent alors il peut aller
bombarder les arrières il peut soutenir
une action depuis les heures une action
terrestre mais il peut aussi bien sûr
essayer d'aller taper la défense
anti-aérienne ennemie il possède un
rayon de combat entre 600 et un peu plus
de 1000 km il a des capacités de
détection assez intéressantes qui lui
permet notamment de détecter des petites
cibles comme par exemple des blindés au
sol et dans ces cas-là de les bombarder
depuis les heures l'une des vrais
interrogations depuis le début du
conflit c'est pourquoi les Russes n'ont
pas obtenu la supériorité aérienne il y
a eu un très bon papier d'ailleurs dans
mes collègues qui s'appelle manuel il
devait dans le dans le Figaro que je
conseille à tous ceux qui visionnent
cette vidéo il expliquait notamment
qu'il y a eu plusieurs choses c'est que
les défenses entiers aériennes
ukrainiennes sont restés performantes
jusqu'au bout et que à cause de
mauvaises performances de missiles les
avions russes étaient obligés de voler
très près du sol et que ils étaient
vulnérables non seulement à la fin la
défense entière aérienne
ukrainienne mais également à des
missiles tirés depuis des mannepates par
exemple
ukrainien voilà alors je vais vous
montrer je crois que cet article là
exactement l'aviation russe a été
réduite au silence malgré sa supériorité
un article retrouvé sur le site du
Figaro pour les abonnés vous n'hésitez
pas bien évidemment à vous abonner pour
pouvoir lire ces articles c'est pour les
côtés aériens alors en termes de défense
entière on a ça c'est ça c'est ça ça
c'est un iris ça c'est un irisé c'est un
système entier aérien allemand on en a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps parce
que c'est ce que l'on disait au début de
cette émission maintenant les Russes ont
mené une grande campagne de frappe
aérienne soit depuis 2006 de croisière
soit dans un certain nombre de cas
depuis des avions et qui détruisent des
infrastructures civiles donc notamment
des infrastructures électriques c'est
évidemment dangereux à l'approche de
l'hiver c'est ce que nous disions tout à
l'heure et donc pour palier ça on a des
systèmes entiers aériens donc là en
l'occurrence est un irisé allemand qui
était mis en service si je ne m'abuse il
y a deux semaines deux semaines et demi
3 semaines en
Ukraine c'est utiliser depuis 2017 par
l'Alma l'armée allemande ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est une très
bonne capacité détection mais notamment
une capacité de tirer à 360 degrés avec
une capacité maximale donc de 40 km et
une altitude donc c'est à dire que il
peut tirer en l'air jusqu'à 25 km et on
sait que ça peut être extrêmement
intéressant pour lutter contre les
bombardements notamment de missile
calibre qui sont des missiles de
croisière tirés par la Russie donc c'est
à dire que là il y a un radar exactement
qui qui détecte c'est la partie du
dessus j'imagine c'est ça peut tirer
alors non c'est dans ce cas là c'est la
partie du dessus qui est la partie radar
donc il va tourner sur elle-même et les
missiles juste un peu à gauche de la
photo et elle pourront lancer des
missiles parfois ça peut être mis en
deux temps c'est à dire que là on peut
avoir un véhicule qui va faire office de
radar et un second véhicule qui sera
chargé de lancer l'initial et on sait
quand l'Ukraine dit par exemple la
Russie nous a envoyé 70 missiles mais il
y a seulement 10 on touche leur cible
c'est grâce à ça c'est en partie grâce à
ça et aussi dans le cas de la Russie un
certain nombre de missiles sont un peu
anciens et eux peuvent avoir louper leur
cible mais également aussi que l'ordre
des frappes de missiles c'est une
manœuvre qui est très très compliqué ça
peut heurter tout simplement un bâtiment
sur la route mais aussi il y a certains
missiles qui ne partent pas soit parce
que dans saucisses à part depuis un
navire parce que ça n'est pas parti
depuis le navire parce qu'il y a des
problèmes mais aussi parce que sur le
coup ça peut être intercepté notamment
par des systèmes comme celui-ci par les
iris que vous voyez ici les iris donc et
on va vous montrer notre une autre arme
qui a été assez pas mal utilisé lors de
ce conflit c'est les highmars les imams
qu'il est sur ce qui c'est aussi sur la
photo qui est derrière nous les neymars
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
peu cette arme qui est américaine chien
américaine c'est l'une des armes les
plus performantes depuis c'est très
centrale du conflit on sait qu'il y en a
16 qui ont été livrés honnêtement ils
ont elles ont fait vraiment leur preuve
c'est système d'arme en fait ont une
portée de le on met un missile donc dans
l'un des citrons c'est ça dans les silos
que l'on voit derrière exactement ils
ont une pardon je j'utilise les termes
assez classique de de dont spécialiste
c'est ça mais c'est exactement ça elles
ont une portée de 80 km ce qui est
intéressant avec elle c'est que comme on
peut le voir elles sont tractées depuis
une base d'un camion donc c'est à dire
qu'elles sont extrêmement mobiles on
sait qu'elles ont été beaucoup utilisés
dans les frappes aux alentours de
carquif donc c'est la contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui a été victorieuse fin
septembre elles ont donc une portée de
80 km ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elles peuvent survoler un dispositif
russe pour aller frapper les arrières et
c'est notamment comme ça qu'elles ont
été utilisées on sait qu'aujourd'hui
elles sont beaucoup utilisées dans la
bataille de Carson donc au sud-est au
sud-ouest pardon de l'Ukraine une ville
qui est assez intéressante pour
l'Ukraine pour deux raisons déjà parce
que c'est la première c'est la
d'ailleurs la seule capitale d'un
noblesse le blast de Carson qui a été
annexée par la Russie qui est peuplé
c'est la plus grande ville peuplée qui a
été saisie par la Russie depuis le début
du conflit et surtout pour eux c'est la
seule ville qui est de la rive droite du
vignette donc pour la Russie c'est
intéressant parce que si elle veut
continuer à avancer de ce côté là et
bien elle a une entrée mais également
pour l'Ukraine si jamais elle veut un
jour à terme reprendre la Crimée il va
falloir qu'elle repasse personne et
qu'elle puisse ensuite basculer de
l'autre côté du fleuve pour pouvoir se
diriger vers vers la Crimée en tout cas
pour les highmers on sait que c'est une
arme qui était extrêmement demandée côté
ukrainien le président
ukrainien volo du meilleur zélinsky
avait fait une demande en ce sens à Joe
Biden depuis qu'elles sont arrivées les
Ukrainiens ont une communication
importante dessus parce que pour eux
c'est vraiment intéressant et ça
vraiment une efficacité redoutable 80 km
c'est quand même très très important
pour un dispositif militaire oui donc en
fait ça peut ce que vous disiez ça ça
fera pas l’arrière 80 km c'est c'est pas
le enfin ne s'étend pas sur 80 km c'est
à dire que du coup on va frapper les
lignes de ravitaillement les arrières
exactement on peut frapper les lignes de
ravitaillement les points logistiques
également par exemple les points
ferroviaires on peut casser des nœuds
ainsi on peut par exemple dans un
certain cas je me souviens que sur je me
souviens plus du nom de la Via mais que
les Russes avaient essayé de franchir
une rivière avec les Ukrainiens étaient
un peu trop loin ils avaient utilisé les
imams pour casser les ponts flottants
mais aussi désorganiser le dispositif
russe ce sont des arbres qui sont
véritablement extrêmement performantes
je pense que si par exemple les
Ukrainiens devaient franchir Carson et
avancer ce seront des armes qui
pourraient être utile par exemple pour
aller reconquérir la Crimée qui est
aujourd'hui un objectif dont les
Ukrainiens reparle absolument et en fait
le commandant en chef des armées
ukrainiennes qui s'appelle
zalujni on a dans un article à écrit que
ce serait son objectif pour 2023 il faut
comprendre que pour les les Russes c'est
un peu leur Alsace pour les Ukrainiens
pardon c'est un peu leur Alsace-Lorraine
c'est un territoire qui leur a été
enlevé il y a un certain nombre d'années
désormais ils ont toujours parlé de la
reprendre c'est un objectif stratégique
on sait que pour la Russie également
c'est un objectif stratégique à
plusieurs égards déjà parce que ça leur
permet d'organiser un dispositif
militaire parce que symboliquement c'est
le premier référendum victorieux qu'ils
aient qu'ils aient gagné même si le
droit international le reconnaît pas non
vu du droit russe c'est une province
russe aujourd'hui et il y a également un
objectif symbolique c'est que la Crimée
pour la réussite pour un certain nombre
de Russes a toujours fait partie de la
Russie et enfin un objectif stratégique
c'est-à-dire que à partir du moment où
vous
bunkerisez la Crimée vous pouvez avoir
une capacité
d'interdiction de zone et de survol
depuis la Crimée d'environ 200 km avec
un certain nombre donc c'est à dire que
vous pouvez sanctuariser d'une certaine
manière une partie de la mer Noire qui
aujourd'hui est il y a beaucoup de
d'autant qui sont en Roumanie en
Bulgarie et en Turquie et ça évidemment
pour les Russes c'est un point de
discorde effectivement alors vous avez
donc on a vos appareils designers on va
vous parler maintenant d'une autre arme
française alors elle est un peu en
petite voilà on va l'agrandir le lr.u
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle c'est
exactement ça c'est est-ce que ça
ressemble du coup aux high mars
exactement c'est d'une certaine manière
le highmars français c'est un système
qui est un peu plus ancien alors on peut
le voir c'était conçu dans les années 80
ça fonctionne c'était conçu par des
Américains c'est qu'on suit également
sur des véhicules qui peuvent se mouvoir
en l'occurrence c'est un peu moins ça
peut tir un peu moins loin que le highmr
américain puisque ça peut tirer qu'à 70
km aujourd'hui ça n'est ce système le
ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
avait révélé dans une interview parisien
que sa livraison était à l'étude
aujourd'hui en tout cas il n'est pas il
n'a pas été livré est-ce que m'avait dit
un expert c'est que c'est à la fois un
croisement entre les canons autant
classiques de 155 mm et les imams et que
de tel système peuvent être notamment
utilisés pour faire de la contrebaterie
la contrebatrice et lorsque l'on a un
système d'artillerie qui va essayer de
détruire le système d'artillerie ennemi
et donc avec une portée de 70 km
évidemment ça peut être un avantage
alors justement on en parlait enfin je
voulais en parler aussi parce que c'est
c'est ces armes là sont très mobiles et
l'idée c'est qu'une fois qu'elles ont
tiré elles doivent bouger rapidement
pour pas se refaire tirer derrière et
exactement c'est exactement ça donc la
mobilité peut être un avantage de deux
manières la première effectivement pour
ne pas se faire repérer mais également à
partir du moment où vous arrivez à créer
une percée elle peut être utilisées pour
avancer en même temps que le dispositif
de l'avant et pouvoir bombarder
bombarder derrière donc voilà pour le
LRU ici nous avons on va dire quelque
chose dont on parle depuis le début de
ce conflit de la société française la
fierté française de ce conflit puisque
même les Ukrainiens en ont fait une
petite vidéo pour nous remercier
absolument
la chose qu'on leur vend le bus qui sort
en tout cas le plus utile donc je pense
je pense que c'est l'une des armes
françaises en tout cas qui est le plus
utile c'est vraiment l'une des fiertés
de l'armée française de manière générale
c'est canon ont été utilisés notamment
pendant l'opération Chamal en Irak par
l'AR française c'est un canon qui a une
qui peut tirer à plus de kilomètres de
plus de 40 km et qu'une précision de 50
mètres donc là évidemment 50 mètres ça
paraît énorme mais c'est extrêmement
précis pour un canon d'artillerie ça
peut aller jusqu'à six coups minute à
partir du moment bien sûr où les
artilleurs sont bien formés encore une
fois ce dispositif peut se mouvoir parce
qu'il est monté sur roues et il peut
donc se promener on sait que le
Président de la République a annoncé la
livraison en tout cas l'étude de la
livraison de 6 annonces César
supplémentaires ajoutez au 18 déjà
livrés ça autorise qu'on appelle une
manœuvre dynamique des feux c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir tirer se mouvoir
retirer mais également permettre une
contrepatrie dont on parlait tout à
l'heure les Ukrainiens comme vous le
soulignez on fait une petite vidéo pour
nous voilà pour nous remercier parce
qu'effectivement c'est l'une des armes
qui est pour eux le plus
utile je pense et je crois que c'est une
des armes aujourd'hui l'un des canons
d'artillerie qui est le plus précis et
l'un des meilleurs de sa catégorie
est-ce qu'on sait combien de temps ça
met parce qu'on vous disiez ça tire ça
se déplace ça retire est-ce que vous
savez en même temps ça met pour se
mettre en place avant de tirer alors ça
dépend bien sûr de la capacité des
artilleurs je ne sais pas exactement
combien de temps ça met je pense que ça
dépend bien sûr de la capacité de
formation des Ukrainiens on sait que un
certain nombre de militaires ukrainiens
ont été entraînés par l'armée française
notamment sur ce type de dispositif on
peut imaginer qu'ils vont
progressivement monter en compétences
donc il y en avait 18 il y en a 6 de
plus c'est ça donc ça fait 24 et il y en
avait 109 qui était prévu donc c'est
quand même colossal comme il y en a 109
qui sont mises en service dans l'armée
française dans les 6 donc les 18
premiers ont été pris sur les stocks de
l'armée française dans les six derniers
qui ont été à l'étude c'était une
commande du Danemark d'accord je crois
de 18 également et on a demandé au
danois si on pouvait en prélever 6 pour
les pour les livrer aux Ukrainiens et
ensuite recomplétez le stock dans un
délai un peu plus lointain c'est aussi
l'une des questions qui va se poser
l'armée française et à la base
industrielle de technologie de défense
française c'est-à-dire dans quelle
mesure est-ce qu'on est capable de
produire rapidement des armes françaises
non seulement pour l'export pour les
livraisons mais aussi pour notre propre
usage parce que si on prélève sur nos
stocks il va bien sûr falloir recomplété
Baptiste commentaire par contre niveau
masse notre armée elle est ridicule il
juge avec seulement 100 César
effectivement par rapport à ce qu'on
sait comment les américains ils ont des
mars par exemple alors en lançant on ne
sait pas et je pense que il faudrait il
faudrait rechercher mes américains ont
de toute façon un stock qui est
absolument colossal je sais pas si
l'armée française est ridicule mais
encore aujourd'hui je voyais un stock
c'est-à-dire que depuis le début du
conflit l'armée russe a perdu
l'équivalent de 7 fois le nombre de
chars possède l'armée française
aujourd'hui en activité donc on imagine
que pour un conflit de telle intensité
les pertes matérielles sont énormes et
c'est aussi l'un des enjeux qui va se
poser faut-il avoir un matériel
extrêmement performant extrêmement
novateur évidemment avec une technologie
coûteuse donc on peut grand nombre ou
alors faut-il avoir énormément de
matériel un peu ancien ce qu'on les
Russes au risque d'avoir une perte et
peut-être aussi une perte de qualité
donc de qualité au niveau de de ce
qu'ils utilisent donc donc voici pour le
canon César est-ce que là maintenant
c'est peut-être son pendant son panda
russe une fois de plus
catchuchka le catch a exactement c'est
c'est aussi connu pour le Parlement de
orgue de Staline alors là les requêtes
ont une portée alors ça dépend les
requêtes bien sûr qui peuvent le Staline
ça montre que c'est assez vieux comme ça
c'est un modèle assez ancien modèle qui
était en utilisation dans l'armée
soviétique déjà il est également utilisé
dans la bataille de dans la guerre de
Tchétchénie la première comme la
deuxième et les tchétchène de son
souvenir parce que la ville de Rosny
avait été quasiment entièrement rasée
c'est une arme qui est extrêmement utile
et notamment ça avait été utilisé parce
que ça peut porter une arme qu'on
appelle thermobarique donc ça pulvérise
un héros seul explosif près du sol et
c'est une arme qui est conventionnelle
mais qui extrêmement destructrice si la
Russie avait utilisé cette arme c'était
également pour montrer à un moment du
conflit je crois que c'était en mai
qu'elle est capable d'aller très très
loin dans l'utilisation d'un armement
conventionnel la therm c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très vraiment très destructeur et c'est
quelque chose qui avait un peu inquiété
certains états majors occidentaux et
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui la rend si
si les trucs en fait c'est que au moment
où elle va exploser elle va aspirer
brûler l'oxygène qui se déroule enfin
qui est autour pour créer une explosion
encore plus puissante qu'un qu'une bombe
qui va exploser au contact même du sol
d'accord donc ça va avoir une une
ampleur qui va être un peu plus
importante effectivement alors ms qui
nous critique puisque nous parlons de
d'armes il nous dit voilà vous vous
parlez de vous comme si c'était des
jouets on vous explique juste voilà
quels sont quels sont les des armes dans
les conflits moi je sais qu'on fait
souvent des des lives sur ce qui se
passe en Ukraine on nous demande souvent
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est à
l'oeuvre et voilà on voulait en parler
justement vous expliquer quels étaient
les armes mais sans le sans le glorifier
c'était juste pour vous pour vous
expliquer qu'est-ce qui est en place sur
ce conflit donc ensuite on voulait
parler aussi des chars des chars qui
sont
déjà russes ça c'est le char T72 qui est
un char qui est ancien dans l'armée
soviétique puisqu'il avait été
extrêmement extrêmement produits
le short et 72 peut permettre de percer
les lignes ennemies d'appui et
l'infanterie mais également d'identifier
détruire assez rapidement des cibles en
restant mobile
le problème du T72 un peu comme tous les
chars de manière générale c'est qu'il
est extrêmement dépendant de la
couverture aérienne parce que s'il est
pas protégé par par les l'aviation
évidemment il est très vulnérable à la
destruction par exemple d'artillerie
ennemi ou en tout cas d'aviation et demi
ces armes c'est charte et 72 sont été
assez utilisés notamment au début du
conflit c'est là où les Stingers
suédois et britannique ont été très très
utilisés le
tesson de 12 a une petite faiblesse
c'est qu'au niveau de la tourelle il y a
une toute petite faiblesse qui permet
aux missiles anti-char de se loger là et
d'exploser donc de faire beaucoup de
dégâts ça fait beaucoup de dégâts et de
le et de le détruire finalement voilà
c'est ce que c'est compliqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que c'est des armes
de début de conflit les Russes sont
beaucoup servi ils sont rendus compte
que ça marchait pas de temps que ça et
ben en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
à partir du en fait je pense qu'il y a
eu plusieurs phase du conflit mais déjà
lorsqu'ils se sont concentrés sur le don
basse c'est l'artillerie qui a été
extrêmement utilisé parce qu'ils ont
voulu pilonner le dispositif ukrainien
et comme pendant la période soviétique
beaucoup le pilonner et ensuite avancer
grâce à l'infanterie depuis que
l'Ukraine a repris d'une certaine
manière l'initiative en utilisant
également des armes à longue distance
donc comme le highmars ou peut-être
bientôt le LRU pour pilonner le
dispositif arrière le désorganisé et
ensuite faire une percée les armements
se sont adaptés le char on sait qu'il
peut être très utilisé pour avancer
avoir une longue avance et protéger des
flancs de d'un infanterie par exemple
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui le ça
le char serait très vulnérable à un tir
d'artillerie et demi si commencé en
trois gros ongles à cause du manque de
supériorité aérienne russe effectivement
on va parler maintenant de de quelque
chose qu'on connaît bien en France
puisqu'on l'a vu dans beaucoup de de
théâtre d'opérations c'est le vade VAB
c'est ça c'est levable véhicule de
l'avant blindé c'est un véhicule de
transport de troupe il y en a qui ont
ils étaient utilisés par exemple pendant
l'opération barkhane au sel c'est un
véhicule qui est assez ancien il était
conçu dans les années 70 il est toujours
d'ailleurs il en a un peu plus de 2000
je crois encore aujourd'hui en service
dans dans l'armée française on sait
qu'une sens une soixantaine à peu près
ont été livrées c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est un véhicule blindé qui
permet d'avancer très rapidement en
protégeant des hommes ça peut en prendre
je crois entre 8 et 12 personnes en
fonction de la taille pardon du véhicule
blindé aujourd'hui il est en cours de
remplacement par un nouveau un nouveau
dispositif qui s'appelle griffon qui a
un véhicule beaucoup plus moderne s'éva
bon une faiblesse et c'est que le
plancher est vulnérable notamment ou
mine un certain nombre de nos soldats en
ont fait malheureusement
on était malheureusement victime et que
ils ne sont que peu armés alors là on
peut le voir sur cette invocographie du
service infographiste du Figaro c'est
qu'ils sont équipés d'une tourelle de
12,7 c'est le calibre voilà exactement
le calibre donc ça c'est une arme qui
est assez intéressante le problème c'est
que c'est quand même vulnérable à
l'artillerie également un peu comme le
char ça nécessite une bonne soit une
bonne couverture aérienne soit en tout
cas d'avancer dans des zones dégagées ou
alors d'avancer très très vite dans le
cadre d'une percée parce que sinon c'est
extrêmement vulnérable oui c'est pour
transporter on est en ayant suffisamment
on va dire de protection mais en même
temps c'est pas enfin regarde c'est pas
kamikaze quoi il faut il faut être il
faut être sûr de ce qu'on fait voilà il
faut être sûr de ce qu'on fait néanmoins
ça permet effectivement de transporter
un certain nombre de militaires dans des
conditions sécurité important mais
encore une fois sans supériorité
aérienne on est toujours vulnérable au
tir ennemi effectivement je vois vous
parler des dernières armes plutôt des
missiles on voulait parler de de
domicile les premiers ce sont des Miss
dont les Russes ont pas mal parlé à un
moment du conflit c'était des missiles
hypersoniques ça c'était notamment le
missile Kinja qui avait été utilisé en
mars
c'est hyper Sonic ça peut aller jusqu'à
Mac 5 c'est-à-dire que ça va aller à 5
fois la vitesse du son exactement
c'est ce côté hypersonique n'a pas été
confirmé du côté occidental donc il faut
rester très prudent ce système qui gel
avait été testé par la Russie pour la
première fois en 2018 et notamment c'est
une ça peut être chargé d'une munition
nucléaire c'est aussi pour ça que la
Russie l'avait utilisé parce que c'est
un côté symbolique de montrer que ça
peut être aussi utilisé sur les théâtres
classiques mais sans charge nucléaire il
y avait du côté de la Russie à un moment
où on s'inquiétait déjà de l'aspect
nucléaire du conflit une peur de se dire
mais en fait s'ils sont si les rues sont
capables de tirer ce type de missile
serait-il capable d'utiliser une charge
nucléaire sur ce type de missile et de
d'avoir une trappe nucléaire alors je
réponds l'abeille cool mais Baptiste tu
as déjà répondu ce serait pas plutôt du
127 mm de calibre le VAB c'est bien 12,7
effectivement notre service infographie
avait vérifié et j'imagine que morue
aussi de toute façon d'article alors je
voulais juste vous montrer une petite
infographie aussi de notre service
infographie c'était celle-là on va
devoir la zoomer un peu puisqu'elle se
met toujours un petit mais pour
expliquer à quoi sert en fait
l'hémicile hypersonique c'est en gros
pour éviter de se faire détruire au vol
c'est ça exactement et en fait ça peut
aller jusque dans l'atmosphère donc ça
peut être difficilement détectable ce
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
que ça va donc très loin comme le montre
le schéma mais également ça peut monter
enfin ça peut avoir une altitude
extrêmement importante plus de nom un
côté un peu imprévisible et donc est une
arme de destruction un peu importe alors
au début qu'on en parlait ça ça peut
faire des espèces de zigzag en fait pour
éviter ça c'est ça exactement ça peut
faire ça et justement ben alors c'est ce
que l'on voit d'ailleurs sur le schéma
ça peut avoir un planeur hypersonique
donc voler une certaine altitude pour ne
pas être détecté tout en ayant été
préalablement aider une altitude encore
plus importante pour encore une fois ne
pas être détecté par le système de
défense et demi et pour ne pas qu'il
soit détruit et je voulais vous parler
de ça aussi des Harpoon des artpoules
qui ont été dont on n'a pas parlé aussi
au niveau de la flotte absolument le
muscva qui était l'un des l'une des
fiertés militaires russes qui étaient
coulées par les Ukrainiens en avril
dernier les apunes sont des missiles
polyvalents sont des missiles anti
navire effectivement ça peut toucher
une cible dans un rayon d'environ 300 km
donc ça veut dire que par exemple si les
écrits dans les installent depuis les
côtes
ukrainiennes elles peuvent frapper par
exemple la Crimée et donc ça évidemment
pour la Russie c'est un danger important
mais pour les Ukrainiens c'est
évidemment
d'autant plus d'autant plus intéressant
on sait que elles peuvent être modifiées
pour être utilisées comme des batteries
côtières ça pour les Ukrainiens ça
pourrait être intéressant pour l'usage
que que je que je décrivais un peu avant
mais ça peut être également polyvalent
donc ça peut être utilisé parfois depuis
un avion ou depuis un navire de surface
un avion qui
de la mer ou de l'océan et qui ensuite
viserait une cible et que le missile
irait directement jusqu'à la cible en
ayant été en acide ayant été bloquée
comme on dit depuis le depuis l'avion
très bien et bien merci beaucoup Amaury
en tout cas merci ce petit ce grand même
état des lieux de de comment se passe
cette guerre qu'est-ce quelles sont les
forces en présence vos articles bien sûr
sur ces sujets sont à retrouver sur le
site du Figaro la suite des lives c'est
à 18h vous aurez rendez-vous avec point
de vue et bien sûr une grande soirée qui
vous attend sur le Figaro puisque c'est
les mitermes ce soir et vous aurez un
débrief demain matin à 8h et
figurez-vous qu'on va parler militaires
aussi demain à partir de 13h
puisqu’emmanuel Macron annoncera la loi
de programmation militaire depuis Toulon
et la fin l'opération et la fin de
l'opération Barka d'a priori aussi merci
à Mori en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
et merci à vous et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux live sur Figaro
live